[Music]
well when you get it when you get a DM
from Sean and a message from Chris to a
record yourself watching this week's hot
ones and be brace myself and then your
phone starts blowing up I think okay
well better learn myself and embrace
myself so without further ado this is me
watching Russell Brand I'm hot ones
is there a leaderboard mmm leaderboard
early table is a graph that I can be on
we have this super fan who tweets out
his power ranking it gets really into
them walk good nine his name is Brett
Baker great I'd like to reach out to you
presumably in a marathon milk or bread
baker likely to bear that statement in
mind when judging me when I'm at the
cleverly respectable level of three five
seven mad dog what I think Brett Butler
is making it on this right bigger skirt
by John do you think he's making of all
this you know talking football and these
local brands are talking to him directly
he's like that Brett is like a random TV
producer in Lincoln Nebraska who just
loves hot ones and just write these
Power Rankings up all the time you know
who's fine because he's a man using
canoe brusca read he should let me press
baker's dozen student is LITTLEST makeup
student isn't he the power right wake up
his name's Brett breakup bread maker
value me bread baked Akash you see I'm
drinking milk coming through all the hot
sauces my Parmesan fire [ __ ] call me a
liar but with being true strike a hot
chili sauce Tabasco elucidate he thinks
we've been through the war we try the
hot one we've even had ghost pepper
blueberry the conscious tea bread baker
we went through directly third my
hundred and I continued on the palm
bread baker it wasn't enough to blow up
the British brunch my dog three point
five seven I stare down the barrel I'm
singing you this Carol fresh major let's
take it to the air
no bread take a breath cuz we've taken
down the [ __ ] Megadeth
brett-brett
oh my god for you I've transcended to a
world of rhyme everything I say now will
be poetic until I eventually just shut
down my consciousness that is amazing
there's no point asking a question
because you can't go anywhere from there
Wow thank you you cleared the board
please
amazing what what do you say wow that's
insane
Thanks I I know words Russell I am
flattered humbled honored highly amused
as always I don't even know how you do
with Power Rankings anymore the Power
Rankings of Ages have to retire on that
because there's no way I can't be biased
you sang a song to me all the love
congratulations on going out and and not
joining the list of shame Wow
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend